[Music]
hey you guys it's tuesday yeah yeah
yeah i'll tell you what
[Laughter]
i had never seen this movie see that
amazes me i had heard about it but i
thought they were talking about a movie
from the 2000s
no
okay no
so
i find out this [ __ ] is from 1987. i
watch it this [ __ ] movie's [ __ ]
awesome man see i knew you wouldn't like
it i had no idea
it had half the it had half the cast of
aliens in it
i know it's really interesting well
katherine bigelow who directed it this
was actually her first uh solo directing
uh job uh well she was uh married to
james cameron for a little while not
when she was um she wasn't married to
him when this was made but i think she
married him like a year or two they
passed the damn movie theater downtown
and on the back aliens was playing you
could see it up on the kiosk yeah it was
because he had bill paxton in there had
that woman that girl that played uh
and it even had the general plate
spaceship yeah
and um
it's a vampire flick and also one of the
guys in the bar um
during that iconic scene
was
uh was the guy that in uh terminator 2
that uh the t-800 or whatever like stole
the clothes from okay yeah all right so
there was another
crossover and then um
this is a good flick because it's a
south vampire's in the south
and you got a damn cowboy who gets
turned into a vampire young cowboys he's
kind of like the dashing kind of like
leading man type he's like the hero
and then they got this bad damn
dirty [ __ ]
vampiric
vampiric [ __ ]
bikers kind of like
scooter
trash yeah
but like one of them's an old
confederate soldier who's running the
[ __ ] he's fought in a civil war and
everything that's [ __ ] badass that's
the dude that played [ __ ] bishop
what's his name uh lance and richard
lance henderson yeah and he was in
pumpkinhead yeah
well maybe he's been in a ton of [ __ ]
obviously this this [ __ ] here man [ __ ]
if you haven't seen this you got to see
it this this is like well it's like a
western essentially but like kind of but
with vampires it's like
this i think this predates interview
with the vampire but you could see a lot
of anne rice lore in this well it
predates the movie predates the movie
that's what i meant you can see a lot of
anne rice lore in it and and it's
it goes right along with the interview
of the vampire it's not quite as classy
you know it doesn't go back to like the
1700s you know with all that frilly [ __ ]
you know what i mean you know i [ __ ]
love it or vampire tom cruise [ __ ]
rock that movie i don't give a [ __ ] what
jd says but anyway the uh well i know i
said he was good in that i've always
said he was good on that so this this uh
this uh cowboy gets turned into a
vampire he's forced to hang out with
these damn bikers
basically they're vampires doing [ __ ]
nasty ass [ __ ] they're trying to make
him kill people and stuff
he's kind of like louis in a way
and then uh
they got this hot girl with them and she
was the girl from the wall she was the
one she played the teenage girl who had
to blow her way in behind stage to get
to get the pink and she kicks her out of
the room during the wall it's that same
girl
she's cute as [ __ ] she looks real young
but she's pushing 30 in it if the
numbers were right
jenny wright is her name i had i
recognized her from she was also in
saint elmo's fire although she didn't
have a real big role in that she was
like rob lowe's ex-wife i think okay i
haven't seen that movie in a long time
she looked like she was a teenager in
this movie but she was she was in her
late 20s at the time yeah but she was
very well preserved for late 20s um well
i kind of feel like most people still
look okay in their baby yeah most people
don't start looking really hard until
they're late 30s she looked real [ __ ]
soft though she looked like a 15 or 16
year old girl
to me
well maybe that's just because we're
older maybe because we're
no
because uh yeah i'm pretty good i can
estimate pretty well women's age what
they're supposed to look like
but um
no
this is a great movie there's a lot of
things about it that make it great it's
got a [ __ ] great score it's all
it's what you would call nowadays
[ __ ] new retro wave which is coming
back into style it's got [ __ ] really
cool 80s shots colors and sounds
and it went from 80s new wave score
to um
power metal 80s power metal sometimes it
was [ __ ] really good it's had that
john parr song naughty naughty in it god
i hated that song well it came out in
the bar in the bar it was in the bar
yeah your [ __ ] happened in the
background i'm talking about the actual
score yeah the score no i know i'm just
that i just thought of that during some
of the action scenes they're playing
[ __ ] power metal and stuff you know
no lyrics just
and i was going oh man that's a [ __ ]
really good score
and just the way everything's shot and
the [ __ ] filters and the cut and the
and the acting and everything it's not
real dot heavy dialogue based it's
situational it's an adventure it's just
a good movie real good movie i can't
believe i had not seen it i was going to
say speaking of music i really liked
also in the bar scene they had uh the
cramps version of fever in the back
which you know yeah
every movie should have that because
it's like a wonderful cover because i
love the cramps but yeah so somebody
already brought up uh lost boys yeah so
what ended up happening with this is
better than lost boys yeah a lot of
people like this one better i'm not
really sure they're kind of it's weird
because
on the surface you wouldn't really think
it it's like yeah they're both vampire
movies but when you think about it it's
essentially the same story similar yeah
uh as lost boys um you know in the sense
that this person you know this guy young
guy gets sucked into like with a vampire
gang uh gets sucked in by a hot woman
and then you know they're trying to make
him kill people and he's like really
kind of um
you know conflicted about it so it's
kind of like the same story as the lost
boys but i guess it didn't immediately
occur to me because the just the
approach of it is so different you know
what i'm saying this one i kind of feel
like what ended up happening with this
unfortunately is that the lost boys had
come out only i think two months before
this
um and it was just kind of like a
coincidence that they were very similar
and lost boys i mean obviously did was
hugely successful this one really not so
much uh it didn't make its movie back or
didn't make its money back in the
theater
and uh it didn't help either that she
had to get the money like catherine
bigelow she had to get the money from uh
dino de laurentiis group
um and they i think went bankrupt like
before this came out so they didn't
really have the money to like promote it
so i think dino de laurentiis movie the
other great one yeah well the thing well
the thing about it like i said catherine
bigelow um you know she had done like
some co-writing and like some
co-directing prior to this but this was
the first movie that she had done you
know directing on her own um she
actually
wanted to do a western
but
because she couldn't get the funding
because you know this was 87 no one was
really doing westerns it wasn't really
you know
a property that anybody wanted to look
at so somebody like recommended why
don't you if you want to do a western so
bad why don't you cross breed a western
with something else and then she's like
okay well i'll do a western style
vampire movie
like i said not really i don't i don't
think there was any uh anything going on
like where they knew the lost boys i
mean fright night had come out a couple
years before so vampires were kind of
like in the zeitgeist i guess there were
a lot like this much better than fright
night too just honestly
in the comments said this is their
favorite vampire movie this is a lot of
people's favorite vampires so i'm gonna
put this right there with the interview
of the van and it's under seen yeah i
mean
they're saying i can't louis is like i
can't believe you haven't seen this i
couldn't believe you hadn't seen it
either because i said this was like just
like right up your alley this is exactly
the type of movie that 1987 i was in my
senior year of high school i was in
brazil
so i was
and it you know what i mean i
i really wasn't going to movies and it
wouldn't have had an on-time theatrical
release in brazil anyway and it would
have been subtitled with [ __ ] shitty
i wouldn't and i was too [ __ ] busy
[ __ ] doing what it what what what i
was doing in 87 was chasing girls and
[ __ ]
so and then i got out went and when i
got out i went back to michigan for a
while i ended up in detroit in the goth
scene
and and i didn't even have a vhs player
in in in 87 or 88
so i couldn't have rented it
you know and as i said because lost boys
as far as vampire movies went with such
like a juggernaut i guess
um and this one didn't really get the
same you know it didn't even make i
think it cost five million to make and i
think it only made like three and a half
million back i did not even know about
this movie well i think a lot of people
don't and it's like a lot of people
didn't know about it back then and i
kind of feel like even nowadays it's
still a little bit under the radar i
feel like even people that are into 80s
movies i mean everybody's seen the lost
boys right but i feel like near dark is
kind of like you know two or three tiers
down it's kind of one of those ones that
you know and but most people that see it
are like oh my god where's this movie
been all my life but it's like it just
doesn't really get the recognition that
lost boys it's like watching terminator
1
and aliens and terminator 2 it's right
there with but it's a vampire movie
cowboys versus bikers i like that it's
kind of like a grounded vampire it's not
like
it's supernatural obviously because
they're vampires but it's not like they
don't focus on that
there's characters in the story fourth
drawer down says lost boys is the
beatles near dark as the stones somebody
said yeah that is that is a good analogy
this is like a very grungy i like that
it kind of and you don't really see a
lot of vampire movies that do this
because i feel like the lost boys and i
love the lost boys okay but um
that one even though it was kind of like
these bad boy rock star vampires which
this is kind of like that too but
they're not pretty boys but yeah in lost
boys it's more like glamorous yes like
this one is kind of like they're all
kind of like scuzzy lowlifes a little
bit and it's like and it kind of focuses
a lot on their
day-to-day
struggle or their day-to-day grind where
they essentially have to like just drive
around in a bus
that they have to like sun proof you
know because the sun will still kill
them and when they go places that kill
people to drink them
um you know they have to like keep
switching vehicles and they have to keep
like hiding out because it's like you
know they don't want to get arrested
even though they're not i mean it's you
know they get shot and stuff like that
it doesn't kill them this is one of
paxton's biggest roles
he's so great in this yeah i don't think
it's his best work but i think i it is
good it is great i think his best work
was the one where
remember that he he was out [ __ ]
catching demons and killing them and you
think he's crazy
frailty yeah yeah we did it yeah we did
a review on that back then that was i
think that's probably my favorite well
because he was kind of well he directed
that too directed and he was the main
character and he just i bought it
i want to get that movie i i just that
was a great that's a great [ __ ]
that's another one that a lot of people
that i feel like if you just kind of
like i feel like real hardcore like
where people like have seen it but i
kind of feel like if you're just kind of
casual
uh you haven't really seen it this can't
be that dude
i can't believe that either yeah i was
watching another like [ __ ] if you think
it was sinister cinema and he was
talking about near dark and he had just
like a couple of days prior to him
recording the review of it he had
actually met lance hendrickson
at a horror convention and he said that
he got into a long conversation with
about bill paxton and about um lance
henderson just talking about what an
awesome dude bill paxton was and how sad
it was that like he died so like
relatively young yeah i think it was
cancer why not i can't remember now i
can't remember what he died of but yeah
and that old no i think he was in his
50s lenny i can't remember you'd have to
look it up
he asked me questions like i'm google i
don't know sometimes she does not know
she does but i can't remember like i
can't remember offhand yeah but i can't
believe i didn't see this one that's
what i was and i told him that last
night because it's like um this one it
seems like kind of hard to get hold of
there's like a special edition but i
even looked on which and the new cover
is cool and everything like that but i
looked on amazon i'm gonna get it we
gonna get this well i looked on amazon
and i couldn't find like they had the
special edition but it was only region
two and it was like because it came out
in france right and then they had a
german version but i don't see one
that's like
the u.s
version i don't know if it's just not
available or it's like and i kind of
feel like
for it now it's on prime video and it's
on shutter even though i think dj maniac
told me that shutter was taking it down
at the end of august because they only
had limited rights to it there's kind of
a lot of
i guess it was a lot of like maneuvering
behind the scenes because the dino de
laurentis group went out of uh you know
went out of business like right around
the time or a little bit after so i feel
like there was a lot of complications
with the rights issues so sometimes it's
really hard to get hold of this movie
some people bag on dino man flicking
that studio they didn't know how to run
a studio i mean they [ __ ] wasted a
lot of money they made a lot of [ __ ]
poor decisions when it came to money
but that studio when it was around was
extremely ballsy about bringing really
oddball productions to fruition
you know flash gordon conan won they did
conan too
um what else did they do [ __ ] a dune
just
real ball this this movie
they probably brought brought out a
bunch of [ __ ] losers too that are
long forgotten but
man
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] that was cool man and
it was really cool it didn't really do
too well at the box office well neither
did this one but then you know but you
look back on it and you go like man they
had it it was ahead of its time a lot of
the [ __ ] they did was ahead of its time
well like i said i like that they
grounded you know even though they had
super powers in the sense that you could
shoot them and they wouldn't fall down
and they were super strong and stuff but
they didn't really have any other
um you know they
and they didn't really go a lot into
like vampire lore they were just like
regular people they didn't have fangs um
they didn't say anything about like you
know crosses or garlic or any of your
regular
fangs just they didn't do close-ups so
you didn't but you didn't really see
them
yeah that's because they were biting
people and yeah they did bite people in
the neck and it did look like they were
like
i think they wanted to stay away from
that stereotypical cheesy ass effect of
the fake teeth on the mouth
i think that's what they were trying to
get away
yeah and maybe that suggested they were
suggested it was just suggested that
they had teeth
yeah they could bite yeah which i guess
would make more sense yeah i would put
it i would put
based on what i saw
it was kind of like an
an anne rice vampire lore
in terms of what they could do they
didn't show anybody float you know or
levitate
yeah that's what i mean you see that
interview of the vampire either the
movie and it was only kind of mentioned
a couple times in the books that they
could just kind of love it to hover and
levitate a little bit
you know and then later on they're
[ __ ] straight up flying
yeah like a superhero louis says uh bill
paxton was 61 61 and died of
complications from surgery he had a car
he had cardiac bypass
and didn't wake up from the anesthesia
oh [ __ ] so he was older than i thought
he was yeah
okay
yeah i'm still 61 is is um well that's
much younger than people should be dying
nowadays i mean i know it happens but
uh yeah and pat's saying i don't think
the word vampire's ever used in the
movie no yeah i don't think it is
because i mean he didn't know what was
wrong with him if you had never yeah if
you had never seen this movie before i
mean it's not called you know anything
with the vampire this or that the other
thing it's just called near dark that
can mean a lot of things so if you
didn't know that it was a vampire movie
um for a long time i mean basically it's
just this dude the cowboy caleb
and he meets uh may jenny wright's
character and you know they kind of hit
it off and even though he's a little bit
creepy and a little a little rapey at
the beginning like hey i'm not going to
let you out of the car until you're like
yeah that's kind of thing so there's
that he wasn't looking enough to get
away with it though
well i don't know
okay
country yeah he was taking his hat off
and he was talking to her he too yeah he
was always taking his hat off like this
like that very gentle like that
it's very funny but yeah so for a long
time like there's this kind of weird
tension like you know
that there's something
weird about her because she says weird
things like she wants to go out and
she's like do you hear the night and
it's like look and she says that the
weird thing about the stars where it's
like you know see that star and it's
like you know the light from that is not
gonna get here for a billion years and
i'll still be here when that light gets
here so you know that i mean obviously i
know it was a vampire movie because i've
seen it before but it's like if you
didn't know that it was a vampire movie
you'd just be like what the [ __ ] is this
chicks deal and then so it goes on a
long time before
and it's almost kind of like and i don't
know if this was intentional i'm
imagining it probably was but it almost
kind of goes like like i said with him
being a little bit like creepy and
overbearing it almost seems like it
could go the other way like he's
victimizing her but then she's kind of
like okay fine i'll kiss you and then
she bites him on the neck and he doesn't
really know what's going on i should
note that i think that one of the
writers on this if i'm remembering
correctly was one of the writers on the
hitcher and this kind of gives me the
same vibe as that it's this is in the
same ballpark as the hitcher even though
the hitcher was kind of more like a
slasher movie
sort of thing
like a slasher road movie i guess hold
on somebody asked me a question tom's
and gloria's bastard says we need
another flash gordon who could play the
role tom
that german guy who was in that [ __ ]
horror movie that we saw do you remember
that guy's name or what i can't remember
his name remember the name of that movie
no that was a while back i remember you
talking about it but i can't remember
they got a german actor
who played a bad guy in one of these
horror movies
um
he's sucking definitely not natural he's
on some heavy hrt and probably doing
some cycles of [ __ ] var or something
but he's not real overbuilt he just
looks like
he looks like and he's he's blonde
and he has that same exact face that was
that was in the flash gordon comics
the the illustrated one from back in the
20s and the 30s he looks just like that
and i sent him a message and he's an
acrobat
he's real athletic he's acrobatic
[ __ ] he does fencing and all that
[ __ ]
and after that movie i did a little bit
of research on him because jenny was
like boy he looks like flash gordon and
i said he [ __ ] does
and i was and this is around the time
where that new flash gordon blu-ray was
coming out the uh the the remastered
blu-ray yeah and i just [ __ ] sent him
a send him a message on [ __ ] uh
instagram real quick and i said man
remember my girlfriend were watching you
in this movie i forgot the name of that
damn movie maybe you guys might remember
it was when we did a matinee on i'd have
to go back and i would i would know if i
scrolled through the titles i would
remember i said you look just like an
illustration of [ __ ] flash gordon you
would make an awesome flash gordon
said uh
[ __ ] try to tell your manager that
you [ __ ] you need a photo shoot of
that because they're probably making a
new flash going one of these days they
need to get you and he just he didn't
answer he just thumbs up what i said
that was it
but i don't know how his english is oak
is good
but you you could always dub him the you
know the [ __ ] the dealer dude the
renaissance guys was dubbed yeah
but uh
you know
because you you'd want a retro accent
and with all the cg
after seeing after seeing that aquaman
because aquaman kind of reminded me of
flash gordon the underwater [ __ ] yeah
after seeing that i was like man you
could do a badass flash gordon nowadays
with cg
but it cannot be a modern [ __ ] flash
gordon it has to look like
art deco
it has to look like the little cartoons
yeah or you know okay that's all i want
to say about that uh david haley said
please review manhunter that's actually
on the list because i've been wanting to
do that for a long time i really love
that movie uh thomas and gloria's
bastards also says you need to review uh
blackenstein you know um that movie i
didn't love blackenstein i gotta say
look i love
blacula and scream blacula's cream are
two of my favorite vampire movies of all
time um
so so of course i wanted to watch uh you
know blackenstein too
and uh and it just wasn't
the production quality is not there
that'd make a good mst it would probably
make a real good it seemed i you know
it's been a while rip tracks i wonder if
rifftrax has done it probably because
they've done [ __ ] everything yeah
they did well the nice thing about
rifftrax in the sense that now that you
can download just the mp3 file they
don't need like the movie to go along
with it um so they can do any movie that
they want to because they don't run into
like rights issues um so they branched
out from doing just like shitty movies
that you know that they could get for
cheap to now they can do ones for like
good movies too uh which is awesome but
i kind of feel like they've done so many
movies
that they must have done they must have
done blackenstein they must have yeah
somebody also said we need to do chud
yeah i kind of remember that one that
was one where the guy's head blew up and
there's an alien inside of him or
something like that that was
cannibalistic humanoid underground
dwellers okay that's all the ones that
lived in the sewers
i remember seeing yeah there was
i remember seeing those a lot like in
cable on cable like back in the day
it was chud and then
uh then there was chud too bud the chud
there was one that i saw where a guy got
bitten by some kind of alien or
something he started to transform his
inner in the in the 80s kind of the
early 80s
and his head [ __ ] blew up like a
balloon he's slowly starting to
transform oh that's um
[ __ ] man uh [ __ ] man oh i can see it i
can see the poster i can see the poster
it was at the time we were really
creeped out by it she saw it like an 84
and i saw it not too long ago what the
[ __ ] is this
back and he started
no well okay mom and his mom didn't know
what was wrong there might be two
different movies that you're conflating
uh there is a movie called
brain damage
that that's the one that has the little
thing growing out of the guys like the
back of the thing but then there's
another movie
what is it called extra is it called the
beast must die
where the dude's like face is blowing up
east man or something or b
i think there's one called the beast
must die i think that that has that
poster with like the dude's like head
getting really big like a balloon but
brain damage is the one that has like he
has like little alien creature or
whatever that's growing in the back of
his neck the little guy named remember
his head blew up and it had the beast
within that beast within that's what
it's called
i knew it was the beast something yeah
beast within that's it east within yeah
because i could see well yeah because i
kept the beast yeah yeah that [ __ ]
tripped me out man as i've been 84 i was
[ __ ] in mid mid teens i was just
going oh [ __ ]
and we that was the most graphic movie
we had seen up to that point i think i
remembered it being
[ __ ] more hardcore than the thing i
don't know if it was but i just
remembered it being
scary
for the time
i don't know it may be easy if i see it
i think it is because i saw it probably
about
yeah that's probably what it was i
probably i saw it like three or four
years ago i want to say it felt all
illicit and we're supposed to be
watching and i didn't remember it being
like terribly scary although it was like
pretty gory but i don't think it was
more gory than the thing okay
i don't remember which one i saw first
maybe i saw that before i saw the thing
i don't know been a long time have you
guys done the fly one and two you know
what i don't have we haven't done the
fly yet have we
the david cronenberg one
[ __ ] we should and the second one's
actually not too bad either like the one
with eric stones beast within yeah yeah
the beast must die that's the werewolf
movie that's right um yeah i forgot
about that
i was just looking at that title of that
the other day extro was the one where
the [ __ ] head little walking soldiers
and the alien powers i think yeah good
guy wasn't it yeah no it wasn't a good
guy want a good guy okay that was a
weird movie they were eating little
gelatins and jellies were turned into
well there was like a whole egg monster
jellies well no there was a whole bunch
of eggs that's what it was and the funny
thing about extro
is that you know the one scene where i
mean you do get to see like a full-grown
man
alien come out of a woman's vagina so
that's something yeah yeah yeah and um
yeah
you know that's another one case anyone
want to be recommended we were watching
those around the same time so they were
getting kind of conflated well me and
you watched it not too long ago like a
few years back and then there was um
and then you know the scene where one of
the aliens has like
it's like this it's crawling on all
fours but it's like legs and stuff are
like on backwards
i've seen that footage because i think a
lot of people haven't seen extra it's
kind of a little more obscure i think
it's british
um
and i've seen that that scene from that
movie like put on youtube is like oh my
god real monster sighting because i
think people don't realize that that's
from a movie but it's totally from a
movie it's from extro but it's like it's
a creepy scene like this thing like
running across the road like with its
legs all backwards and stuff but it's
just it's a man doing this yeah sorta
well yeah like it's it's yeah it's weird
it's weird but um yeah sheila answered
whatever happened to jenny wright so big
back then yeah she was in a bunch of
[ __ ] and then she just kind of like
disappeared uh i looked and saw a
picture of her recently she's
unrecognizable
yeah well hard living it looks like to
me
but uh but like i said she was in a lot
of movies like around this time period
like in the 80s and then but i kind of
feel like that happened to a lot of
a lot of uh people back then but yeah so
no well that girl we saw that woman we
saw from uh the other night in that damn
vampire movie barbara crampton barbara
crabbe just [ __ ] smoking hot at 62.
yeah but that's not i mean that's she's
kind of a little bit of an exception to
the rule yeah you know
gotta say most most women when they're
62 like don't look that good yeah that's
for sure um although like i said it's
you know it's better now than east being
now that everybody's kind of like
people understand health understand
things and it's like you know there's a
lot more [ __ ] that you can do to keep
yourself from like looking like yeah and
don't smell like an old hag don't snort
up all the blow and uh don't drink a
fifth of [ __ ] vodka every every night
you know [ __ ] well it's just that's
just good all-around life advice
that's another thing uh people look up
these old stars you cannot judge stars
but you can't they're not accurate
judges of the aging process some of them
seem to never age and other ones by the
time they're 60 you're just [ __ ]
totally unrecognizable it's because of
the hollywood scene man they're doing so
many drugs
you know a lot of drugs and a lot of
alcohol abuse especially certain
generations and the thing about it is
that i think there is a genetic
component too because some people can
get away with it for longer
um it eventually catches up with you
like no matter what you do and also i
kind of think that more some people are
more willing to like you know for
example go get surgery or something like
that
yeah so so it does kind of come down to
the individual in some ones that are
abusing substances are [ __ ] hit
stop
stop being shown in movies because they
look like [ __ ] so you don't you don't
see them you go back and look for them
and you're like god damn and it's
because they've drunk themselves to
death and done a lot of drugs and
partying yeah they almost look like
homeless people some of them some of
them might be homeless people
uh it wasn't nick nolte was kind of a
homeless guy wasn't he for a while
uh that well i'm not sure if he was
exactly homeless but they do kind of
because i kind of there's there's a
running gag on riff tracks like go from
movie to movie because mike nelson does
like a really good mcnulty impression
so he's always every time there's a shot
in a movie whatever it is of like a bomb
or something like that he'll do the nick
nolte voice
under the impression that he's
couch surfs and that is kind of baby and
is kind of homeless uh or at least at
certain periods yeah and he's definitely
[ __ ] crazy all right uh he did he did
some good performances though so you end
up with kind of a [ __ ] bum mentality
on a lot of them and other ones have
enough money to where
they can just do [ __ ] fantastic
[ __ ] hormone therapies and just keep
cutting flesh off and nipping and
tucking and nipping and talking small
procedures every couple years you can
[ __ ] stand on top of the [ __ ] me cher
was doing that forever
i haven't seen her in a long time
but at 40 cher looked about like 25 when
she wanted to look that young
yeah how she was dressing
danny rowling asked what our favorite
parts of near dark
um okay so
i think every most people are gonna say
that extended bar scene like that ten
minute long uh kind of bar thing where
they come in the bar and start like [ __ ]
with people and stuff which is a great
iconic scene
but you know what i think my favorite
scene
was the one at the end where
the kid vampire homer
um
when they're like you know when uh caleb
is going to get like his sister back and
may kind of essentially tries to like
sacrifice herself like she jumps out the
car with the little girl and it's like
you know giving him back and then the
the kid vampire homer goes like running
down the road in the middle of the day
like after like this she's mine she's
mine and then like he just starts
burning up and for 1987 uh that was a
really good fire effect i was surprised
and then he essentially explodes yeah i
was gonna say the uh the shootout rescue
scene where he back where he runs the
dam
that was great too and in there to get
runs the van and yeah and all the all
the gun shots are coming in with all the
little like the things shafts of
sunlight and they're all like the smoke
and everything coming out of them and
then like that comes
around up around all the wind the
windows so the sunlight can't and they
had spray paint too like they were spray
paint i said oh that's nice they like
prepared for everything like big bags
full like duct tape and black spray
paint and tin foil and [ __ ] and it's
every time they like steal a vehicle
they have to like sun proof it yeah um
you would think well like i said
they don't really it's interesting
because they don't really imply you know
that um jesse like lance henriksen's
character you know that he's been alive
at least since the civil war because he
said that he fought in the civil war um
and
so but some of the other ones and i
think may hasn't been a vampire that
long because i think she says she makes
a reference to like not having been a
vampire that long and the interesting
thing though is that the kid vampire
homer is implied i think they imply that
homer is the oldest one although they
don't because they all the other ones
call him old man
so
it's interesting because like you said
like anne rice kind of went into the kid
vampire thing lost lost boys they also
had a kid vampire
although i think he got changed back
uh at the end like when they killed the
head vampire um you know so he didn't
stay a vampire but
it was interesting and here's something
that a lot of people brought up is that
when homer the old you know the kid
vampire that's actually an old man
goes after
uh caleb's little sister sarah who's
what 10 or 12 or however old she is
and um that seems a little weird because
even though
uh you know homer looks like a kid he's
actually an old man but he's in a kid
body
and so some people were like well that
seems really weird like he's a pedophile
or something but
just from the optics i thought the
implication in the movie
was that homer had made may into a
vampire with the hopes of her being his
companion
but because she was an older woman like
she was a high school student or you
know or in her 20s or whatever when she
got turned
maybe she still perceives him as a kid
even though he's an old man you know
what i'm saying so it's like maybe homer
feels like he doesn't have any choice
except to like turn a kid into a vampire
who will kind of be like you know even
though that kid will also
that killer age 10 years ago be an adult
yeah so like i said they kind of went
into the same thing with
claudia in you know the anne rice
stories even though you know she had a
lot
she got it kind of a lot shittier
because like i said in the movie
she's
how old was uh kirsten dunst when she
did that movie to 12 14 something like
that in the book claudia was she looked
a lot younger
yeah in the book claudia was six
um so which would have been really
[ __ ] up like in a movie but can you
imagine can you imagine being turned
into a vampire when you're six years old
god damn that would suck hard somebody
says can i j this is fourth drawer down
says could i suggest the lost crustle
movie called me the mean season i've
heard of that
was that based on something else was
that based on a set in florida i don't
know oh okay i kind of feel like i've
heard of that and i didn't know if it
was based on a book or if it was based
on like a real case mike barrett says
there's an interview with jenny wright
on youtube lots of drugs and alcohol
yeah pseudo there you go yeah
uh yeah hugo said i like when they're
all smoking
[Laughter]
tom says that tom's glorious bastard
says zarados is what a director looks
like
on
director on drugs to look like well
zardos though actually i want to buy
that except that's kind of like
accidentally genius just because it's so
[ __ ] bonkers i don't think it's that
i don't think it was an accident
that director did a really good really
good job on excalibur excalibur is one
of my favorite movies uh if you guys
haven't seen it you should see it you
know it's it's kind of like la morton to
artur yeah it's john borman right yeah i
think is what his name is
um zardoz is actually [ __ ] pretty
intelligent when you think about it it's
a breakaway civilization of a bunch of
kind of like you know
hippie type [ __ ] intellectuals that
live in paradise and then they're using
people to depopulate the planet and a
big [ __ ] head comes it's using
religion and giving people guns and he
goes [ __ ] guns are good the penis is
evil and [ __ ] you know it's a crazy
movie
[Laughter]
yeah what's his name is like the
enforcer for the
he's just he's just like in uh
worshiping zardoz
who's his god but it's really just a
flying [ __ ] robot head that that the
rich people use to fool him and the
killing and enslaving of everybody on
the planet and they're keeping records
of his f computer records over what he
does how many women he's raped and how
many women he's killed
it's just he's getting like high scores
it's it's [ __ ] bizarre when you think
about it
but they got that
that was part of the of a series of
movies that were coming out around that
time like silent green and a mega man
and where they're looking at u.n
writings that talk about [ __ ]
depopulation agendas and [ __ ] that and
global warming or global cooling or
whatever that that's what they're
getting at that's what they're talking
about
man made
man-made
depopulations and disasters
that the elites want to do to everybody
else
i think this i thought it was a genius
movie i want to see it again i liked it
i like it it's bonkers yeah it's [ __ ]
crazy it's crazy yeah i forgot to point
out when you were talking about the
score of this movie that uh tangerine
dream did oh really okay yeah yeah
that's right sorry so good yeah right i
remember that they did a bunch of they
did a bunch of movies uh just piece for
now says never seen this but don't see
how it can beat fright night well okay
or friday no i'm not gonna say that it's
so it's hard to say because fright night
is it's just a totally totally different
vibe like i said this is more like
the story is kind of similar to the lost
boys but in tone it's more like the
hitcher it's like the hitcher meets the
lost boys
if that makes any sense
and it's kind of also like a western you
know what i mean so it's kind of this
gritty
scuzzy
you know it's just these vampires
driving around but like i said they
don't call them vampires there's nothing
like that's what they are crazy yeah
that's what they are but they're not
like they're basically just going around
just like predators but they're also
this kind of like weird [ __ ] up like
family yeah so they're almost like even
though they're kind of scuzz bags but
they're a little bit sympathetic too in
the movie in the movie in this universe
they don't have the term vampire they
have vampires just like in some zombie
movies they never use the word they
don't
no one uses the zed word
[Laughter]
okay now uh one
most people like i said that that have
seen this movie love this movie
but one criticism that i see of this a
lot
um
is that people don't like the end
because they think they end as a cop-out
did you think the end was a cop-out no
i don't either but i can see how people
would think that
i know what they did though
i remember 87 quite clearly
people like to have happy endings in
movies they didn't like a depressing
ending they liked to like feel
walk out of the theater feeling good
like you saw something oh yeah it all
worked out that's what they were going
for back then
some studios would actually make
directors change the endings of the
movies to make it end happily well we
just went uh on a whole thing about
little shop of horrors about that which
will be up later in the week about that
they had to hold take that whole ending
out because artistically not that good
but i remember those times and
a lot of it had to do with their
their you had cable but televisions was
crt television it was low resolution it
looked like [ __ ] really
um
vhs recordings vhs machines were out
there but they were very expensive
you're talking about over a thousand
dollars
and video rental was really not really
uh well yeah it was a thing at this
point but to buy a video movie was over
a hundred and something bucks just to
have a [ __ ] vhs tape yes
yeah [ __ ] ridiculous because they
they wanted to keep control over [ __ ]
factory movies
um that didn't last long though uh so
what was happening was you had people
basically of all walks of life
a lot of them would be what you would
call today housewives
going to the movies to blow off steam
and escape reality for a couple hours
and they wanted to leave it
and come out of the theater in a
positive
mood
because they they didn't want anything
heavier
you know depressing
so the theaters kind of knew this
it was not about art it was more about
getting people sitting in a damn [ __ ]
theater seat
selling selling tickets which that's
that's that's good
what they should have done
in in in in these cases where they
changed changed the end of the movie
they should have preserved all that [ __ ]
so when you
you could sell two different versions of
it on vhs that's what they should have
done
although i kind of feel like they
weren't thinking that far ahead because
nowadays you know nobody cares it's like
oh even if we have to take this scene
out we'll just put it on the blu-ray and
it's like in the deleted scene so people
still get to see it back then you didn't
really get that particularly when it was
you know when [ __ ] was just on video
very very rare for you to have like a
deleted scenes at the end of the vhs you
didn't really get that there wasn't like
special [ __ ] on it what i would have
done although it probably wouldn't have
occurred to me at the time
i would have if i'd owned those studios
and had rights to [ __ ] make and sell
the vhs tapes i would have i would have
sold two different vhs tapes one of the
directors to cut the other one
theatrical cut and [ __ ] double dipped
on the [ __ ]
i can yeah some some studios did like
get in on that like pretty early
but i feel like it wasn't really a thing
until later because i feel like it
wasn't a thing until like laserdisc
became briefly a thing because there was
a lot more you know memory on there and
it's like they were trying to
get people to buy laser discs which were
expensive and laserdisc player which was
expensive so a lot of people like oh
look at all these special features we
have this documentary about the making
of and like deleted scenes and stuff and
so i kind of feel like i remember when
that came that was a weird concept
because in 87 there was just the movie
it's just a movie this idea of a
director's cut and a theatrical cut i
would have known what the [ __ ] you were
talking about and i would imagine the
average person wouldn't have known what
the [ __ ] you were talking about only
like a movie buff would know what a
director's cut was
yeah well because like i said even even
way back in the old days it's like
there's always been like different like
varying cuts of movies yeah um you know
going back to the beginning of cinema
because you have different markets it's
like you know for we can have more
nakedness in the european version than
the american version or whatever it was
but yeah i kind of feel like the public
at large wasn't really
that aware of that until later on yeah
some of them were so badly cut up
that they don't know [ __ ] what the
original was and they're not sure how
many movies have been spliced together
like a
fan of the opera did you know that yeah
founder of the opera is like three
different movies put together the old
they don't know what the original looked
like
yeah i mean there's no way of knowing
unless somebody like took some writing
and there's [ __ ] missing some of them
there's a
scene where a guy comes out of a cave
and talks to you but there's no audio
and he says there's talk and they don't
know what that was
yeah some edits have that taken out
some somebody must have been in in the
silent film
era would have done a voice over a live
voice over at that point
but then they because they changed it
from black and white silent film to
[ __ ] a hand colored talkie
and there was several different versions
of it from the very beginning running at
the same time that's weird when you
think about it
they don't know the original family
opera they don't know what it was
well that happened with a lot of stuff
well silent movies some silent movies
like i think i'm thinking of like london
after midnight and stuff like that where
it's like they just know the title and
the posters and some stills but they
don't know where the movie is like the
movie is lost they don't have it yeah um
somebody said oh alien from l.a yeah
that was the one with kathy ireland that
was on uh mystery science theater it's a
good mystery science theater episode
that movie is like [ __ ] terrible
though um
pat says off topic but is the original
ending of little shop of horrors on
youtube yes it is uh because we did a
review of it which is going up thursday
if you're a patron friday if you're not
um and we talk about that at length and
i actually talk about what the original
ending was like if you've seen the
off-broadway play um it's that ending
but they shot that for the movie but
test audiences didn't like it because it
wasn't a happy ending uh so you know
but uh charlie watts died uh he was 80
years old yeah somebody said charlie
watson and keith richards is still alive
keith richards never going to [ __ ]
die man he's pickled
he's got to be at this point so yeah we
were talking about alcohol aging you
know i'm like well it seems like if you
drink a really lot then it'll like has a
preservative effect you said the
tangerine dream did the uh the the score
for this
and uh it was a great [ __ ] score i
loved it and it's like
it's back in style this sound
the kids [ __ ] love it you could put
this score to a new movie and give it
that same kind of tone and this does
have a lot of pink in it a lot of
[ __ ] blue
in the sky and [ __ ] yeah it looks just
like one of these looks well that's what
that's what a lot of the movies nowadays
are like hearkening back to you that's
good now there was another movie that
tangerine dream did the uh did the the
did the soundtrack for they did it for a
lot of them yeah but i want to see if
you guys remember this it was called
thief
i think i had khan in it james khan i
think it was a start in it and i
remember it as a kid i remember liking
it but i don't remember anything about
it and i haven't seen it in a long time
but if you guys if you guys think that's
a good movie drop a comment
in there and maybe i'll get that well
you can probably like look at it
i mean look it up on a streaming service
because it's like if it's not you know
if it's a situation like transfers where
you thought it was a good movie and you
started watching it and then you're like
what the [ __ ] this is terrible it's
about a
professional like safe cracker and he's
being hired to [ __ ] get get into this
vault and he has to go through this
[ __ ] bizarre ass way but i don't
remember all the details just remember
him with goggles and [ __ ] trying to
weld through and cut through things with
torches and [ __ ] louis says it's
excellent is it excellent i might have
seen it it sounds kind of familiar when
you're talking about it and [ __ ]
tangerine dream did the [ __ ] score
did they do the score for legend
i want to say i kind of feel like they
might have
i wanted to say a little bit too about
because it's a great movie yeah
because here's uh i was going to say
something about katherine bigelow
because like i said it's interesting
that she started her
uh directing career in horror even
though that wasn't originally her
intention like i said she wanted to make
a western but nobody would give her
money to make a western so she made like
a vampire western and uh obviously i
think most people know she went on to
win an oscar later for the hurt locker
she also made uh zero dark 30. she made
strange days which is actually a pretty
decent movie point break which a lot of
people like uh k19 the widowmaker with
uh harrison ford was in that you know
what i found out today that i did not
know
do you remember the video
when did this come out 87 i want to say
the new order song touched by the hand
of god and the video is like a parody of
like a hair metal
uh they show they show it at eyebar
sometimes and it's like it makes me
laugh every time catherine bigelow
directed that
i just found that out today and i was
just like delighted because i've always
really like that video always [ __ ]
cracks me up because it's funny if you
know anything about new order like
seeing them all dressed up like 80s glam
metal and like pretending that they're
like do it like and singing but touched
by the hand of god like this that kind
of like technically pops on you guys
remember funny as [ __ ] if you guys
remember thief there was another one i
was trying to remind jenny of that i
remember too it was kind it was a
gangster movie about kind of like a
retired girlfriend of a gangster she's
like in her 50s or something and she
ends up saving a little boy who lived
next door whose family got whacked it
was called gloria and it's kind of like
the professional just [ __ ] chick
older chick protecting this little boy
trying to keep him from getting killed
and they run off together she saves him
it's called gloria i remember it being
really good but i think i might have
seen that on cable that sounds kind of
familiar also i don't remember if my
memory i don't know if my memory is
accurate but i remember liking it it was
some blonde chick she's probably 50
something and he's probably about five
and she's trying to protect him from the
mom she's a she's the girlfriend of a
mom like a retired girlfriend she got
too old to be a girlfriend so he had to
retire you get a younger one you get a
younger one because she's living in
luxury in a way trade her in she yeah
she's kind of living in a she's living
okay though in new york you know [ __ ]
he he takes care of her and i i remember
it being really good i was thinking i
was considering seeing that one too
yeah sheila ann said she's seen it
gloria with gina roland yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm pretty sure i've seen that
i don't i remember you should have seen
that
um
it sounds so familiar because i saw so
much [ __ ] like on you know in the mid to
late 80s like early 90s like i saw so
much [ __ ] on cable that it's like i feel
like
everything like every time you bring up
a movie and kind of talk about like man
that kind of sounds familiar too so i
might have seen that i remember it kind
of kind of being like
the movie the professional where you had
the [ __ ] assassin who was protecting
the little girl i remember being kind of
like that but it was like
the roles were reversed
yeah sheila ann uh
said that uh
she was married catherine bigelow
presumably was married to the director
of titanic um yeah she was married to
james cameron i think they were only
married for a few years though and when
she made this movie i think she knew
james cameron this time but they weren't
married yet but this was like yeah this
was like her directorial debut so it's
like it's cool that she started out in
horror you know he's also they're also
mentioned the movie the keep that was
another one i gotta see again i put that
one in the patreon poll last week but it
didn't win you can you can rent it on
amazon prime i think it's 299 or 399.
the nazis bust into this damn stone
[ __ ] fortress and then there's a damn
golem
yeah a jewish golem yeah and it [ __ ]
the nazis up
they told them not to go in there
nazis they don't
[ __ ] listen they don't listen well
they had some kind of silver
kind of like a cross it looked more like
a tea
some kind of ruinic things all around it
it might have been something hebrew
they had and they were silver embedded
into the walls and they removed one of
them because it was worth money yeah
they got out they're like
yeah it was those things were holding it
in there it's pretty [ __ ] cool dumb
ass nazis yeah but yeah yeah i've been
i've actually been wanting to do a movie
respect on that for a while i mean like
i said ever since we kind of expanded
out the matinee live streams to do like
old movies too because remember for a
long time for whatever reason we were
just doing new movies on matinee and
then saving the old ones for movie
retrospectives and i was like why bother
doing that because there's so many i
have this massive massive list of not
only new movies but i have a massive
list of old movies that i want to talk
about that people have requested that i
want to do and it's like we're never
ever going to live long enough to review
all these movies unless we
go back and do some of these older ones
so if you want to do the keep at some
point like next week or whatever
we can do that because like i said i put
it in the patreon poll i think last week
but it didn't win that's one of them
that i want to have and i knew that you
really liked that movie so it's like i
definitely wanted to i'm pretty sure i
looked it up and it's i think you can
run it on amazon prime and i think it's
299 or three minutes yeah that's funny
it's so tempting because that's just
cheap to watch but some of these ones i
want to own them yeah but yeah we'll
we'll work it out yeah but seriously if
you
i didn't really
okay so when i was talking about near
dark i didn't say exactly what happened
at the end i just asked you if you
thought the ending was a cop-out i was
gonna say what happened to the ends when
you talk about it but in some ways i
feel like there's a lot of people that
haven't seen it because like i said
it seems like one of those movies
that even though it's awesome
it just it kind of flew under the radar
i think a lot of that was to do with one
because the marketing budget because you
know of dino dillard is company going
under kind of going under around the
same time and also because of lost boys
coming out a couple months before and
kind of like being a big hit and being
essentially the same story even though
like i said the the approach of it is
completely completely different so even
though
on the surface it's like the same story
as the lost boys kind of um just the way
that it's like tonally it's completely
completely different it's more like i
said it's more like a western scuzzy
sort of hitcher type
thing more than a glammy yeah rock and
roll type thing louie's in there saying
that thief has a lot of help elements of
the movie heat
yeah which i liked heat even though
certain parts of heat i thought were
kind of slow
it was still an okay movie
the heat was really good in in in the
context of it of the day that it came
out i would imagine that had i seen it
when it came out i would have really
been blown away i think i saw it in the
theater but by today's standards there's
so many good movies and so many good
crime
series that you can see since this you
know i mean where
it's kind of stolen the thunder going
back and seeing it isn't probably as
good as as as as if you'd saw it well
that's what's kind of like in a way
that's like bad but in a way it's good
because
you're thinking because i'm not one of
those people it's like no don't they
don't make good mobility anymore blah
blah blah like all this good stuff it's
like every time every era has good [ __ ]
and honestly there's so much good [ __ ]
nowadays particularly as like series and
stuff there's great movies nowadays too
but there's so much good [ __ ] it's like
an embarrassment of riches yeah series
is where it's at really in general
yeah i like that they've been able to
like expand the storytelling because
people are more receptive to
that but nowadays going back in time
they had some good [ __ ] in the 70s 80s
oh yeah 90s like i said there's good
like this movie here stood out i was
like oh man this is an excellent movie
see and i told him afterward because
i've been bugging him to watch this one
and then i was like it was kind of hard
to get hold of and then finally shutter
added it and i was like we're finally
gonna do this
and so like after he watches he's like i
can't believe i never [ __ ] saw that
he's like that's an amazing movie and
i'm like see i knew i was like this is
exactly the type of movie it's like
right up your alley and i just could not
believe that you had nothing i was in i
was 20 minutes into it going this is a
great movie yeah it's great yeah
just just the soundtrack i mean just the
way it looks it looks like a western
like it's just very like it's all dusty
and sunsetty and it's just yeah the sun
sets with the orange and the pink and
then the [ __ ]
new wave [ __ ] score in the back and
it just they're going yeah they they got
this one right
they got this one right and just uh the
tonal the visual tone of the movie would
be dark and dark and light at the same
time it just
looks it's good you know i mean really
good it's just kind of
yeah there's an element of nostalgia
to it because of that that that score
but it's fresh you could put that score
you could put that score in a movie
today and [ __ ] people would love it
yeah because i've been doing it because
i've seen recent movies that had a score
that sounded very much like that it just
really kind of brings that movie up it
brings it alive yeah
and really i'm hard on a movie
when it comes to uh
to to score
if you've got a shitty score you just
don't have a [ __ ] movie
it's interesting how much it matters
because i kind of feel like a lot of
people don't think about it it's
something that a lot of reviewers don't
even bring up unless it's really really
noticeable but it can really like make
because what the score sounds like
really goes a long way toward what the
tone is like the mood that the movie
evokes
yeah it really does like make a big
think about it alien one would not be
that movie without that [ __ ] score
and i think in horror and sci-fi it's
even more important than it is in other
genres i don't know you know that's you
know that's my opinion i don't know if
anybody wants to argue with me about it
but alien one would not be a movie
without that score imagine if you had a
70s [ __ ] funk [ __ ] sound or
[ __ ] rock or something sorry just
imagine alien with the seventies [ __ ]
that movie
did you know that originally originally
star wars was gonna have a [ __ ] disco
i had heard that a disco
it would the movie would have bombed and
been forgotten it has to have a
classical [ __ ] score
yeah because that kind of stuff i mean
for that type of epic movie i mean you
need a timeless
you can't have something that will
specifically date it to a particular
without that [ __ ] score alien one
would have flopped yeah that's what made
that [ __ ] movie that's what made that
movie that's what gave that movie the
intensity and the and that's what made
it eerie and scary
and it's not really music
yeah kinda
it's music and then same thing with
[ __ ] the thing the first thing that
boom boom
yeah
yeah it's just that yeah
but that that's all you need well i like
look at john i mean and john carpenter
does his own scores for that he did
halloween which of course is iconic um a
lot of his stuff is very simple but a
lot of this stuff is you know simple and
sometimes more effective depending on
what you're doing or what you're trying
to evoke and it's like like i said if
you don't think like score or sound
effects or anything like that matter
that much watch a horror movie with the
volume down see how scary that [ __ ] is
it's not
[Laughter]
yeah um somebody said yeah hugo said
even in the 2000s when i was looking for
near dark on dvd nobody knew about it
yeah i feel like it's it's one of those
kind of like lost classic type of things
um yeah he says there's dvd and blu-rays
of it but i think the blu-ray is out of
print yeah i kind of feel like it's
because amazon they had like a really
nice special edition blu-ray that had it
had a dvd and a blu-ray on it but they
didn't have one for for us region one
that's region one right uh they had a
region two one
uh and they had one that was french
language and one that was german
language but they didn't have a an
american one but i did like the new
title like the new title art that they
have like the cover art is nice i like
that it's very kind of
um stylized and i thought it was bill
paxton like even though
because i you know everybody loves bill
paxton everybody loves lance hendrickson
uh so obviously they're gonna get
uh you know all of the poster facetime
you know they're gonna put them on the
poster really big because they're like
the selling point even though they're
not really the star of the movie i mean
they're not they are but they're not
like the main character like adrienne
pazdar that guy from uh
that's playing caleb he's kind of the
main character
but yeah we'll be reviewing more um
hammer flicks
oh yeah i definitely want to do more
hammer play i mean there's so many like
i said i have a humongous i have a list
like new movies over here like new
meaning like 2010 forward and then i
have old movies like over here and it's
just like this huge
huge list like some of them i'm gonna do
like on just on my show especially if
it's something that's kind of already
party or something you don't really give
a [ __ ] about but
you know i just have a massive list and
then there's like some really obvious
movies that i haven't done yet which i
can't believe but i was just looking at
my list today i'm like oh my god i can't
believe i haven't done that one or that
one or that one
so i don't know i'll get around to it
well we've made this an hour though and
i think we've said all we can say about
this movie this movie was a [ __ ]
fantastic movie now i gotta have it yeah
it's on shutter right now yeah although
i've heard that it's not going to be on
shutter for much longer so if you don't
have shutter you might want to watch it
i think it's on amazon prime too but you
might have to pay for it they're saying
it's hard to find this on blu-ray it
well yeah that's what i was just saying
that it's like i just saw like a
european they couldn't even find it on
dvd yeah it's like because i was going
to do it because you know how like i
have the i have the amazon storefront so
a lot of times when we review a movie
i'll put it in the storefront and i was
looking for it earlier today i'm like
what the [ __ ] they only have like a
european special and the special edition
they have in europe is like really nice
but
we don't have one so you know yeah
somebody needs to get on that
screen
factory yeah
but like i said it might be a rights
issue because i did kind of feel like
there was a lot of that's why it doesn't
turn up anywhere yeah scream factor you
ought to get on that [ __ ] until shutter
got it it was like really even hard to
find it to stream anyplace yeah you know
what i mean so if you want to see it
like i said i'm pretty sure it's on
amazon prime you might have to pay a
couple bucks but it's on shutter at
least until the end of this month maybe
uh so you might want to check it out
before it goes anyplace uh if you're
into vampire movies and you haven't seen
it if you're into 80s horror and you
haven't seen it uh if you're into if
you're into catherine bigelow's movies
and you haven't seen it you want to see
her first one uh here it is and it's
like and it's really really good lost
classic man up there with t1 and [ __ ]
aliens too it's like that yeah it's
great it's a great movie all right so we
will be back tomorrow what's today's
tuesday right yeah okay well so we'll be
back for the side track show tomorrow
night we'll be back tomorrow at 5 00 p.m
getting drunk and talking [ __ ] like like
we usually do on wednesdays wearing wigs
yeah all that kind of stuff fighting
[Laughter]
like whacking each other
yeah there you go it'll be it'll be that
it'll be super fun we'll think of
something to talk about all right so
thanks everybody for dropping by and we
will see you guys tomorrow evening